تكشف تفاصيل الجديده بشان الوثائق المسربه
ان كل شيء بدا منذ شهر يناير الماضي عبر
تطبيق ديسكورد وهي منصه للتواصل الاجتماعي
مصممه خصيصا لمجتمع العاب الفيديو في
مجموعه يزيد عددها على عشره بقليل بدا عضو
مجهول نشره ملفات وصف بعضها بالسري للغايه
تتضمن تفاصيل بشان الحرب في اوكرانيا
ومعلومات عن اعتراض الولايات المتحده
اتصالات عاليه المستوى لدول حليفه لها
كاسرائيل وكوريا الجنوبيه الى جانب تفاصيل
عن الاختراق الامريكي للخطط العسكريه
الروسيه ما بين شهري يناير ومارس ظل تداول
الوثائق المسربه محصورا على هذه المجموعه
الى ان عمد احد المستخدمين الى اعاده نشر
عشرات منها في مجموعه اخرى تضم عددا اكبر
من المستخدمين
وفق محللي استخبارات مستقلين فان من بين
الوثائق المسربه اكثر من 50 مستندا تصنف
في خانه السريه والسريه للغايه يعتقد
مسؤول الدفاع في الولايات المتحده انها
يمكن ان تكون اصليه اكثر المعلومات حساسيه
في هذه الوثائق تكشف اختراق الولايات
المتحده للحكومه الروسيه عبر عميل الروسي
شارك معلومات من داخل جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي ومداولات داخليه لوزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بشان توفير الذخيره
كما تفيد الوثائق بان واشنطن اعترضت
مناقشات دارت بين اعضاء مجلس الامن القومي
في كوريا الجنوبيه بشان بيع الذخيره التي
يمكن ان تصل الى اوكرانيا
واعترضت الولايات المتحده ايضا حسب
التسريبات محادثات بين قاده الموساد بشان
دعوه مواطنين اسرائيليين للاحتجاج على
تعديل نظام القضاء الذي تقترحه حكومه
نتنياهو الان وقد حدث ما حدث تجري
الولايات المتحده تحقيقاتها لمعرفه مصدر
التسريبات بدراسه عده احتمالات كان يكون
وراءها عميل لديه حق الوصول الى الوثائق
الرسميه المصنفه في خانه السريه للغايه او
احتمال حدوث اختراق لانظمه المخابرات
الامريكيه ومنذ احداث الحادي عشر من
سبتمبر عام 2001 توسعت قائمه العملاء
الذين يحصلون على حق الوصول الى المعلومات
ذات اعلى درجات السريه ما يعني ان مئات من
موظفي الحكومه الامريكيه لديهم تصاريح
امنيه تتيح لهم الاطلاع على هذه الوثائق